hey guys it's Charlie this is going to
be my flash episode 4 video just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
they did so much comic-book stuff this
was amazing welcome to the new rogues
like mere master and top crowned
themselves the new kings of the city
because Captain cold is gone I'll
explain what they were talking about
because you know they use Captain cold
in the episode even though you know
spoilers for legends of tomorrow season
1 he's off doing other things so I'll
explain the timeline and what's going on
with that because it's a little
confusing with flashpoint but here we go
you know top 10 WTF Easter eggs there
were so many comic book things happening
in this episode so many oh moments
like I can't believe they're doing this
so number 10 the birth of mirror master
so this is flashpoint mirror master so
you know we can guess as to whether or
not he would have existed before
flashpoint but the way they explain it
is that the particle accelerator goes
off as he's in the middle of a you know
rogue war of sorts with captain Cole he
along with everybody else in the room
gets hit with the blast rape captain
Cole barely gets out and he's trapped
for three years so really important
thing number 9 WTF when they're looking
at the footage of the rival die we know
that it's probably not mirror master now
because he had not climbed out of the
mirror when the rival was killed so he
couldn't be working with dr. alchemy yet
but that doesn't mean that he won't
eventually run afoul of alchemy it seems
like alchemy knows about everything
that's going on in the city so
eventually you cross paths with them
zoom style like in the way last year
that zoom had turned all the medes or
killed them like either you're with me
or you're against me and if you're
against me I'm gonna kill you so
eventually mirror master and top will
have to do something with alchemy but
the interesting thing about you know the
person that killed the rival because
they're like could it be somebody that
has different types of powers iris is
the only person who's thinking ahead
although they don't say savat are I
think that's who it's going to wind up
being because the gauntlet is not doctor
Alchemy's gauntlet that's grabbing him
by the neck but the thing is is they're
teasing stories out bit by bit like
giving you clues episode by episode so
if you follow them closely enough you
can see you know like when they do the
big reveal you'll be like oh well they
tease this in this episode so I'll
mention that
with respect to like killer frost and
some of the other ongoing storylines as
we go through the video but number seven
meet the top so the top in the comics is
a man they just gender bent him and made
it a little more clear that she is they
met a human to do just endures his
vertigo it was a pretty interesting
effect but the way you're viewing it
like she doesn't actually warp space in
that way you're just seeing it from that
person's perspective it seems like from
Jessi quicks perspective in mirror Matt
like when she tested out on Mir master
show me what you can do it seems like
the world is warping around you
inception style but that's only
happening inside your mind like she's
not so powerful that she can warp three
dimensional space but number six Barry
and Jessie training montage Jessie quit
getting a little bit better obviously
she's going back to earth-2 so the next
time we see her she'll have a little
more practice probably a little bit
better but I love the way they had Barry
run upside down but they just have a lot
of fun running inside the particle
accelerator and I really love the Big
Brother dynamic that he has with Jessie
quick I feel like he'll get better at
that with time as the flash family grows
like he's kind of a big brother to
Jessie quick but he really is more like
Wally's big brother just because he's
such a part of Joe's family
so the Wally storyline is like a whole
separate thing they barely touched on on
in this episode so number 5 like the
relationship ease stuff that ran across
everyone's storylines so you have Barry
and iris obviously they're going there
it's like very clear they're moving
Barry into a separate apartment so they
could start getting naked together Joe
is even being hit on by this other
person here her name is Cecily and
obviously the Wally Jessie thing is
happening too so you definitely know
that Jessie's coming back if they're
teasing that out so we'll circle back
around to that but just you know the
idea is is that all the dudes in all
these relationships you know Joe Barry
Wally are all afraid to move forward
just because they're afraid of losing
whatever it is that they're gaining like
Wally is afraid of losing Jesse quick
because she's on a completely separate
earth Barry has never had everything
that he's always wanted so he's
terrified by that he'll have so much
more to lose now anytime things get
really happy
everyone gets comfortable that's when
you should be the most worried but
number four very worried about earth 19
Harrison wells
called HR who's just a little too funny
to trust the Harrison wells multiverse
audition this was so great because
Harrison wells from earth-2 will call
him Harry is having some FOMO like he
really will miss the people from STAR
Labs but he is being honest when he says
he doesn't trust this Harrison Wells so
running down the list this is really
cool some of these are Easter eggs from
the comics Wild West Harrison wells is
just meant to be kind of funny earth 17
Harrison wells who calls his earth Terra
Prime is actually in the comics is in
earth it's subject to really terrible
nuclear wars that gives rise to the
widespread proliferation of mutants so
it's basically like this worst-case
scenario type earth like things are
really bad there we have French Harrison
wells who's a mime not necessarily a
comic book Easter egg but definitely
annoying earth 19 Harrison wells is also
a comic book thing so earth 19 is
basically like in earth it's a century
behind in development so it's basically
like an old timey looking version of
Earth 1 but in terms of this crazy
version of Harrison wells he just seems
too over-the-top to be for real so I
feel like something's gonna go sideways
and earth - Harrison wells will come
back eventually to take his rightful
place on the team but anytime something
seems too good to be true like they
definitely slap you in the face with
teasers like killer frost is a good
example they made it very clear which
direction they're headed with her
character so I feel like they're kind of
slapping you in the face with the
weirdness of Earth 19 Harrison wells
saying that yeah something is definitely
going to happen with him and it's not
going to be good but number three the
flash versus mirror master Jessie versus
the top awesome takedowns really like
the way they do the special effects it's
going to be a lot of fun and he'll
definitely be back this season any time
someone's not killed at the end of an
episode they always come back just
remember dr. alchemy is sitting in the
shadows he'll probably have something to
do with mirror master getting out number
two was Caitlin saving the day getting
Barry out of the mirror the important
thing to note here is that Barry did not
see her do it
but my number one WTF post-credits scene
this was like the oh moment where
she accidentally freezes the
shower her lips turn blue her hair
starts to turn white and she tries to
cut it out so you can see where they're
headed with this she's not going to be
able to hide it eventually the episode 7
is called killer frost that's when
things will probably reach a head and
you'll see like full-blown killer frost
whether or not they take it back in the
back half of the season because part of
the problem with doing killer frost
stuff is that it requires extensive
makeup so it's really cumbersome so they
might find a way to kind of bring her
down a little bit but whatever ends up
happening
I do think they'll give us full-blown
killer frost like an oh moment
where she just goes completely blue and
then they'll find a way to give us a
version of Caitlyn that takes that back
before season 4 starts but let me know
in the comments what was your favorite
moment what do you think is going on
with weirdo earth 19 Harrison wells he
is such a weirdo that is totally going
sideways but can we just freaked out
about killer frost this is going to be
so much fun i love danielle Panabaker so
I'm so excited to see her get this crazy
arc this season
the only other Easter eggs that I
noticed there was actually a big mirror
master easter egg because Harrison wells
said the Evan McCullough mirror master
was from earth-2 he's basically the
second version of the character he talks
about the mirror gun the other one was
the Cisco Riddler shout out when he
talks about the riddle that they put on
the board for the other Harrison wells
to solve so ongoing storylines that you
need to keep track of there were kind of
like thus avatar teasers at the
beginning of the episode what if there's
another superhero that can do different
things
the other one was mirror master in top
taking up the mantle of the Rogues
because the traditional rogue characters
captain cold heatwave they're off on
legends of tomorrow so just to explain
that Captain Cold died during season one
but flashpoint time-travel kind of
brings him back he will be part of the
Legion of Doom while heat wave is
travelling with the legends but that's
all happening on legends Captain cold
will come back to the flash eventually
but in roundabout ways like you saw in
this episode so effectively the flash
has kind of cycled the membership of the
Rogues and now mere master is leading
the team but what'll happen is is I'll
do like a flash trailer video tomorrow I
also want to do like a fake punished
a ghostwriter team-up trailer like a
Marvel hearts of darkness just for fun
so look out for that and ask for air oh
it seems like interest level has been
like falling in arrow videos so I might
not do arrow episode videos until we get
to the mid-season crossover like I'm not
going to be doing Supergirl videos in
the same way but I will do like four
night crossover videos just for the
stuff that people aren't super
interested in I'm not going to do every
single episode but if there's something
really crazy like I might do a Miss
Martian video for Supergirl even if I
don't do a video for the entire episode
so no worries I'm still doing a lot of
comic book TV videos but just in
slightly different ways and I'm still
doing videos for all the episodes of the
flash Walking Dead just started I'm
doing videos for all that they're still
you know still a lot of TV stuff
happening so don't worry like if you
have big questions I'll try to answer
those in the comments but yet I there's
so much comic book stuff happening this
week and there is a new round of the DC
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so that trailer video should
post early tomorrow morning what you
guys waiting for that to post you can
click up top to learn all about the
punisher season 1 cast the punisher max
storyline defenders crossover and you
can click down here for all my other
flash videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you